does the m2 macbook air absolutely
destroy windows laptops well today we
will find out because we have the latest
and greatest dell xps 13 plus here one
that is spec with the same 512 ssd 16
gigabytes of ram it has the latest alder
lake i7 chip which comes with the
efficiency cores as well so not only are
we going to test out and compare the
design the speakers the webcam some
benchmarks as well as real world
productivity tasks but we're gonna test
out the battery life i have both of
these at 60
battery i set the dell to best power
efficiency while not doing anything with
the mac it handles everything
automatically and as we go through this
comparison we will see what the real
world battery life is like because we
know that brands greatly exaggerate the
battery life so now let's go ahead and
jump in now if you guys want a chance to
win one of these new m2 macbook airs
we're doing a giveaway and i don't care
where you are in the world i will pay
for the shipping i'll pay for all the
fees and taxes all i have to do is one
be subscribed to maxtec and two comment
on our launch week videos you can
comment on each video and then on july
25th we are going to be choosing a
winner in one of our videos so make sure
you guys do not miss it don't fall for
scammers you don't have to pay for
anything just make sure to tune in and
to be subscribed now i want to start
with the overall design and say that
this dell xps 13 plus is super clean i
love that the keyboard goes all the way
to the sides we have these
touch buttons up top which apple kind of
got rid of with their touch bar and then
you don't even see a trackpad here it is
built in you can actually press the
surface and it is one of the best
windows laptop trackpads but of course
the macbooks trackpad is better it is
the best on the market the keyboard on
this macbook is also fantastic the dell
is also very good they did a killer job
in such a thin machine now even though
the macbook air has this redesign with
these slim bezels that match everywhere
the dell still looks sleeker more modern
these tiny bezels with the webcam built
in up top whereas the macbook has that
large notch which doesn't take up any
space because they added extra pixels
but it is not as clean now just overall
design wise i love the dell xps i prefer
it it is much smaller overall even
though the screen size is about the same
and it is just a nice sleek machine it's
so sleek that it doesn't even have a
headphone jack on the right hand side we
have one thunderbolt usb c port and they
do give you an adapter in the box
whereas the macbook has a headphone jack
on the left side the dell gives you
another thunderbolt port whereas the
macbook gives you two thunderbolt ports
and a magsafe fast charger which means
that those other two ports are available
for use and you don't need to use one of
them for a headphone adapter either and
with that the dell does cost 250 dollars
more than the macbook as far as the
displays the dell has a higher
resolution 3456 by 2160 compared to 2560
by 1664.
now can i tell a difference looking at
him right in front of me at this far
away no i cannot tell a difference in
sharpness which is why apple has not
increased resolution in the displays
they keep it the same and now on the
dell i actually lowered the brightness a
little bit uh because it was telling me
hey it's an oled screen the brightness
is using a lot of power the mac is
completely maxed out but if you do max
out both of these they're both the same
identical 500 nits dell's oled screen
does have better viewing angles and if
you're watching videos especially hdr
you do get more pop than the plain lcd
screen on the macbook but with that
color accuracy is similar but with oleds
if you adjust the brightness it goes off
so you have to use a calibrator and you
have to keep it the same now when it
comes down to speakers neither of these
have any speaker grills at all they are
hidden inside and apple made a big deal
about their new quad speakers so let's
go ahead and compare them
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys you heard that yourselves
the dell is extremely loud much louder
than the macbook the m2 macbook air
actually got quieter with the redesign
it got a little bit more bass that
sounds more rich whereas the dell
got way louder than before
the highs are crisp now you know how's
deep bass it doesn't sound as natural or
balanced compared to the macbook but i
would take that loudness capability any
day this is the quality of the m2
macbook airs 1080p camera and
microphones and this is dell's 720p
webcam and their microphones go ahead
and let me know down below which one
looks better and which one sounds better
and now let's get into performance the
first i'm gonna do is run this web
browsing test take a look at that
difference i'm using chrome on both to
make it fair 333 compared to 133 now of
course we are set to best power
efficiency so let's switch over to best
performance all right that is a good
improvement but still not matching up to
the m2 chip and with that i now hear the
fans
running
just for web browsing now alder lake
does have good performance it does have
those power efficiency cores but it does
suck a lot of power when you're needing
it and just to show you guys the
difference
i have intel power gadget opened up and
then our power metrics on the mac and
just sitting here we're running at 21
watts
on the dell and it's showing me the cpu
is being used it's running at 2
gigahertz but with that we're using a
lot of graphics power here
i don't know if that's just to run this
high resolution display it takes a lot
of performance now they used to have
even higher resolution ones and i said
it's crazy the battery life was terrible
and now they lowered a little bit but
they made it oled on the m2 our package
power is literally
uh less than half a watt 0.17
0.2
0.3 it's sipping power
incredibly efficient and now let's go
ahead and run geekbench 5 we'll see what
the performance is and also how much
power it uses once again we are in the
full performance mode if you go into the
power savings it will use less power and
slow down your system but here we care
about performance the dell can actually
use up to 64 watts on the cpu but right
now because these are ultrabooks we're
testing them unplugged so it looked like
the peak that i saw was about 25 or so
whereas the macbook it peaked at 21. all
right we have our results and this is
laughable we have a thousand nine
hundred for the single compared to 1182
and
838 compared to 5476
and this is the performance we're
getting because we are unplugged and
it's greatly limiting the alder lake
chip that is a fast chip because it
sucks power if we did have it plugged in
it would be in the seven thousands range
much better and now let's compare the
graphics this model right here is the
acor not the 10 core we think that for
most people it is the better choice we
will be doing an acor vs 10 core
detailed comparison coming up soon and
here we have intel's iris xe high-end
graphics that intel makes for ultrabooks
all right
whoa okay
well
ardell
died on us right when this test got done
now of course i don't know how long you
guys are watching this video for we
shoot these for hours and hours a 25
minute one might be four and a half
hours of shooting
but there's no doubt that this thing is
dying extremely fast especially when we
start pushing the system so let me
grab our cable
plug it in you guys see we got 2639
on the bin acor version of the m2 chip
and the dell got 13 401
that is pretty much
half the performance of the bend m2 chip
now i also ran it a second time plugged
in and then that jumped up to 17472
definitely closer but still off but with
that said the macbook it performs the
same regardless of if you have a plugged
in which is excellent now you guys saw
the dell die so let's talk about the
battery life i think i saw a three
percent rating and i don't know if it
died at one percent or if it died
at i don't know two or zero right now we
have six but of course we've had it
plugged in here our macbook on the other
hand
is a lot better take a guess what the
macbook is at the dell burned through
almost 60
of the battery they both started there
the macbook is at 40 percent yes it only
burned through 20
in all of that use
that is incredible and that is why if
you're doing light use
you can get 12 hours of battery life
real world battery life or mixed use
still probably eight nine hours of
productivity because of how power
efficient it is now of course with the
dell you could get an lcd 1080p screen
that will save a lot of battery life but
then the screen is going to be
noticeably worse you're not going to
have the beautiful colors or the oled so
it's a big trade-off and now i'll test
out some real world photo editing now
for both of these i do have gpu
acceleration enabled for the m2 it does
allow full graphics acceleration but
because the iris graphics aren't as
powerful and it's not the unified
architecture it only allows limited
graphics acceleration with the dell we
are now plugged in and i do have a set
to best performance let's flip through
these raw edited images
as you guys could see the macbook is
switching
much faster
even though the dell does have faster
ssds noticeably faster as far as the
slider performance
we're getting a little bit of
glitchiness right here the fans are
kicked on we are limited by some of the
graphics performance that's a little
smoother there the macbook looks to be
perfectly smooth i mean look at that
guys
insanely smooth i wonder if the dell is
still limiting performance because our
battery is low
it is at eight percent i turned off the
low power mode settings but it could
still be doing that so i'm going to get
wait a little bit for it to charge up a
bit more all right guys we let that
charge up for about 10 minutes we're at
15 now the system cooled down it was
shut down
and now let's go ahead and export these
50 images i have my timer set up right
here and bam right out of the gate the
macbook is flying compared to the dell
our graphics are maxed out and the cpu
is also changing from about half to
close to being maxed out our temps are
also quite up there because it is a
fanless laptop dang and it is done
already that took a minute and 10
seconds the dell is mostly relying on a
cpu and bam we are done
the dell took two minutes and 21 seconds
literally taking twice as long to do
this task when it is plugged in in best
performance mode compared to unplugged
now i'm personally very curious how long
will the dell take if we go ahead and
unplug it and you're somewhere where you
don't have access to plug it in now i
think a lot of times if you know the
battery is not great and you know the
performance drops you will plug it in
but what is the difference we're still
set to best performance on battery power
okay we have our results and that took
three minutes and 42 seconds so more
than three times as long compared to the
macbook if they're both unplugged and
the dell set to the best performance
mode now i also have to let you guys
know that if you buy the base model
macbook air with the 256 gig ssd
and you're running anything else
but having lightroom open it can slow
down dramatically so you have to at
least get a 512 model with the uh m2
macbook air to get this jaw dropping
performance and now let's test out
simple 4k editing because you're not
going to do anything crazy on this dell
a lot of people say even the macbook
can't do it but you guys see the
performance so here i have davinci
resolve studio opened up on both version
18 and when we're just playing back this
4k timeline hevc that does have a couple
effects both of them are playing it back
perfectly and almost right away the dual
fans on the dell started kicking up i
can hear them running in the background
while we're playing back and of course
the macbook is fanless now one
interesting thing is that our macbook is
running really cool even though it is
fanless it has a really good media
engine that is very very efficient so it
looks like our gpu clusters are at 43
degrees celsius here cpu is also very
low now if it starts adding a bunch of
effects titles animations yes it will
start to heat up but here it's fine
whereas the dell it also has media
engines but they are not based on the
same arm five nanometer efficient
architecture and now let's go ahead and
export this short five minute project
our macbook is flying through this
export it took a minute and 32 seconds
to export that that is insanely fast and
the dell took 7 minutes and 39 seconds
that is about 5 times faster
on battery power compared to being
plugged in and of course it would take
longer if it's unplugged and after doing
all of those tests shooting for hours
let's see what the macbook has in terms
of battery life remaining
20
we started with 60 on both
this thing died and the macbook still
had 40 percent we did a bunch more tests
uh with this plugged in the mac
unplugged and we're still at 20 that
shows off the amazing efficiency of
apple silicon and the amazing
performance as well so with all of that
said getting back to the main question
does the new m2 macbook air destroy
windows laptops well if we're looking at
it from the standpoint of a luxury
modern thin laptop using the latest
architecture the latest intel chips and
designs dual fans well yes it does kills
it in performance it is cheaper and the
battery life is way better the overall
experience is way better as long as you
get the 16gb 512 it's still cheaper and
it performs amazing and it's fanless no
no high fans none of that stuff so there
you guys go that is where we are at in
2022.
if you can afford spending 1600 bucks
18.50
the mac is the way to go go ahead and
click that circle above to subscribe and
help us reach our goal of a million
subscribers check out one of those great
videos right over there this has been
max maxtec and i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]